[Music]
time now for final exam we find out who
at Fox is really following the news and
who's just reading a teleprompter just
kidding
the co reporters have metal copters only
I do our defending champion Fox News
national correspondent Lauren Blanchard
who once seated the great Edie Henry
last week on ceremoniously our
challenger tonight another national
correspondent and a perennial contestant
on this show Peter Doocy welcome back
thank you very much thank you for having
and welcome back to you or appreciate
you you know the rules but for audience
at home you may not hands on buzzers I
ask the questions the first one to buzz
in gets to answer you have to wait until
I finish asking it in order to buzz in
each correct answer is worth one point
if you get it wrong we subtract a point
we don't want to what we have to
best-of-five wins
you ready if I'm not ready can I have a
few minutes no you can't own a friend
either first question this week Sex in
the City actress Cynthia Nixon threw her
hat into the ring to run for which
national office Peter Doocy that would
be the governor of New York they have a
governor you sure it's one of the
Cuomo's for now for now the nine p.m.
guy and seen that roll tape is it
governor New York the actress is hoping
to add New York Governor to her resume
together on Monday the Tony Emmy and
Grammy winner and now she would
challenge the incumbent Democrat Andrew
Cuomo Tony Emmy Emmy and grant together
we can win this fight Peter juicy
following the news out of New York all
right congratulations question two are
you ready yeah even Democrats getting
fed up with the mainstream press
coverage of Russia which is non-stop
which filmmaker just complained that the
Russia story is quote a shiny key to
distract us Lauren Blanchard that is
Michael Moore Michael Moore says
something true is it Michael Moore even
some of the networks that we watch
Russia turn the channel Russia all the
shiny keys to distract us that's what
goes on in the media who says Michael
more speaking brush a stalemate between
you one each is he promoting some I
don't know if he's brought him but he's
you know he's all even a broken
FileMaker tells the truth once too long
question three which Hollywood actor is
being mocked mercilessly online for
covering a third of his physical being
with a huge tattoo Peter Doocy
it's Ben Affleck don't believe you he
seems too sensible is it Ben Affleck Ben
Affleck a lot of people talk about Ben
Affleck Ben Affleck's getting teased
online after a recent photo revealed
that he has a giant bat tattoo you may
have seen this take a look Phoenix
bit covers his entire back check out
this new tattoo that his friend Matt
Damon just got he's showing his support
that's good I do have I was in the
Japanese mafia though so that's mine
I'll be curious what that's gonna look
like in a couple years I'm sure even
better as they questioned for at
Buckingham Palace this weekend 77 year
old Richard Starkey was officially
knighted by Prince William stark he's
better known to the world by which stage
name Lord Blanchard Ringo Starr they can
go star of The Beatles ladies and
gentlemen to the tape we go call him Sir
Ringo
Prince William today knighted former
Beatles drummer Ringo Starr he received
the honour under his real name Sir
Richard Starkey been made Sir Paul
McCartney was knighted in 1997 holy
smokes correct answer which brings us to
sudden death - - - Peter Doocy
Loren wins for defending champion
decided by this question number five
which kind of animal was recently seen
walking on two feet at a zoo in
Philadelphia because it is afraid to get
its hands dirty Peter Doocy it is and I
sympathize with this is someone who has
Purell often in his jacket pocket
it's a gorilla a gorilla yeah I thought
they walked on their hand cold and flu
season Tucker it's not to be messed
around let's roll the tape is it a
gorilla male gorilla at the Philadelphia
Zoo
I like likes to keep it very well he's a
bachelor baby he's known for walking
upright like a human as you can see the
reigning is short I just was really
lucky to meet a man like this
in the mud exactly cuz imagine this did
you know the ants for the dead but the
lightning fast of Peter Doocy were too
much I came into the studio this morning
during America's newsroom and I've just
been pressing the button on incredible
well you win the coveted Eric whemple
mug which commemorates his brief but
memorable appearance on our show
congratulations see this week's well
their dad did I hope you'll come back
that's it the final exam this week pay
attention to the news every week tune in
Thursday nights to see if you can beat
our news pros at the news